that's the most important part about it
all if it goes to trial
who's going to flip when they're going
to flip what they know
when they know and who they're going to
point out
and i believe michael cohen has already
started to do a lot of that
i also find it very funny and very uh
coincidental that we see superseding
indictments and a guilty plea from joel
greenberg down in florida
you know the matt gats sex trafficking
case
the the sugar daddy guy down in florida
that was helping matt gatz pay prost
underage prostitutes on his venmo
account
that guy
i believe that that sounds like it could
be
maybe i don't know i mean it's all kind
of coincidental that rudy giuliani was
had a no knock raid
from the fbi the same federal
governments
that's prosecuting joel greenberg and
looking in the matt gatz
and his activity on his electronic
devices i
find it kind of you know coincidental
that rudy giuliani's devices were
were seized because you know what
those names pop up in a lot of places
rudy giuliani was
donald trump's personal personal
personal attorney
he was also representing him during the
the whole big lie
election fraud [ __ ] running around
the country and all these state
legislators
farting on people like literally he was
farting on people
jen ellis was one of them sitting next
to him you see how these names are so
many
so many [ __ ] scumbags that you have
to keep track of
good lord
but rudy giuliani shows up in the
greenberg case
or yes joel greenberg jesus see the
names
the names so many of these [ __ ] [ __ ]
boxes
rudy giuliani's name shows up in that
story
and the reason why is because apparently
joel greenberg
allegedly paid roger stone 250 000.
to lobby for a pardon for him for the
crime the sex trafficking crimes that
he's now pled guilty to